vertrauen ist in der politik ja eine
extrem wichtige währung wählerinnen und
wähler müssen sich darauf verlassen
können dass ein politiker oder eine
politikerin sagte und verspricht es gibt
allerdings im zdf archiv ein versprechen
das immer wieder gegeben wurde das ist
schon eigentlich vielmehr eine botschaft
als ein versprechen anderthalb jahre
lang wir wollen nämlich keine
impfpflicht einführen ich bin gegen eine
impfpflicht es wird keine impfpflicht
geben wieso haben denn alle keinen in
absehbarer zeit oder stand jetzt
eingeführt es hatte ja keiner von ihnen
pandemie erfahrung genauso wie von uns
keiner pandemie erfahrung hatte und in
einer solchen lage absolut zu erklären
eine impfpflicht wird mich kommen gerade
in der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz so kurz vor
weihnachten wurde jetzt klar die
impfpflicht soll ausgearbeitet werden
und sie wird kommen das ist fast so
sicher wie das amen in der kirche nur
warum setzt die politik überhaupt tabus
die sie nicht halten kann können wir der
politik überhaupt noch vertrauen
[Applaus]
erst einmal ist ja wichtig wann
überhaupt was versprochen wurde die
pandemie begann vor zwei jahren im
dezember und ab märz kamen dann die
erste welle und der erste doktor michael
kretschmer der ministerpräsident von
sachsen hat ja schon vor fast zwei
jahren sich festgelegt hört man zu was
er in der bürgersprechstunde gesagt hat
so eine art impfzwang immer deutlich
sagen das ist unfug niemand wird in der
bundesrepublik deutschland gegen seinen
willen geimpft das gab es nicht und das
wird es auch in der zukunft nicht geben
zur selben zeit hat sich in spanien der
gesundheitsminister auch schon
festgelegt ich gebe ihnen mein wort es
wird in dieser pandemie keine
impfpflicht geben da gab es übrigens
auch noch keinen impfstoff ist ja klar
und es gab noch mehr große worte wir
wollen nämlich keine impfpflicht
einführen die eben sich nicht werden
impfen lassen wenn das mehr als 40 50 60
prozent der bevölkerung seien solche
dann werden wir noch sehr lange eine
maske tragen müssen masken tragen wir ja
alle immer noch aber jetzt soll auch die
impfpflicht kommen der offizielle
impfstart in deutschland war ja erst am
dezember 2020 jens spahn nannte das die
größte impfkampagne in der geschichte
deutschlands wow nur die grundlegende
frage ist doch eine ganz andere warum
hat die politik überhaupt so
kommuniziert in einer absolut neuen lage
in so einer absoluten lage die niemand
kennt warum da diese klarheit die
antwort liegt wohl in einem wort dass
jens spahn genannt hat kampagne es ging
darum vertrauen aufzubauen die
bürgerinnen und bürger sollten darauf
vertrauen können dass es keine
impfpflicht gibt sie sollten freiwillig
zu dieser impfung gehen im politiker
werbe deutsch heißt das dann hört man
ganz genau hin wir haben gesagt es wird
keine impfpflicht geben wir sind am
beginn sozusagen der phase in der wir
noch wärme wo wir mehr impfstoff haben
als wir
personen haben die sich impfen lassen
wollen neben bereitschaft ist sehr sehr
hoch und ich glaube nicht dass man durch
veränderung dessen was wir gesagt haben
also keine impfpflicht jetzt vertrauen
gewinnen würde sondern ich glaube wir
können vertrauen gewinnen indem wir für
das impfen werben aber bald wurde klar
die impfquote ist einfach zu niedrig und
da liegt der hase im pfeffer doch als
das klar war da war ja sommer sommer
sonne sonnenschein und irgendwas war
doch dann noch ach ja die bundestagswahl
und laschet söder berbalk habe klingt
nach sie alle hatten vielleicht eher die
umfragewerte im blick als die inzidenz
werte und außerdem haben sich schlechte
ein oder andere gedacht was ich heute
verspreche das muss ich vielleicht gar
nicht halten
[Musik]
dieses umdenken das konnte ich live
miterleben als ich vergangene woche die
familienministerin einem spiegel
interview konnte dies von den grünen und
früher auch jemand die mit der
impfpflicht eher skeptisch war aber
jetzt jetzt sieht sie es anders als es
nix mal haben wir eine kleine panne mine
wahnsinnig dynamische situation es ist
ein sehr komplexes infektionsgeschehen
und politik ist gefordert vor allen
dingen vorausschauend zu agieren um
mögliche nächste wellen auch
schnellstmöglich zu erkennen und schon
prophylaktisch zu unterbinden dass es
gar nicht erst auch zu einer überlastung
des gesundheitssystems kommt das muss
wirklich das maß aller dinge sein es
gibt natürlich schwerwiegende gründe in
der politik würde man sagen eine
veränderung der umstände führt zu einer
veränderung der haltung mal ein paar
beispiele zum beispiel die grünen das
war immer die anti kriegspartei und dann
regieren sie und müssen einen
militäreinsatz zustimmen kosovo 1999 und
jemand aus der pazifistischen partei
schmeißt auf den eigenen außenminister
ein farbbeutel
fukushima die größte denkbare
katastrophe in einem atomkraftwerk und
angela merkel mit der cdu die partei die
immer für die atomkraft war steigt von
jetzt auf gleich aus der atomkraft
wieder aus eine radikale kehrtwende
besondere umstände erforderten eine neue
haltung was ist das denn eigentlich ist
das eine lüge ist das eine kehrtwende
ist das eine einsicht vielleicht passt
ihr ein vergleich viele gehen eine ehe
ein und sagen bis uns der tod schaltet
und dann und dann scheitert die ehe und
war dann das was wir in dem moment
versprochen haben eine lüge oder ist das
was dann folgt eine späte einsicht oder
bekommt dann die kehrtwende versprochen
gebrochen
[Musik]
keine impfpflicht das war das
versprechen aber jetzt jetzt sind wir in
einer pandemie schon lange ein
gesamtgesellschaftlicher
schicksalsschlag wie krass die situation
ist das wurde mir persönlich irgendwie
klar als ich mal die bilder einer
kollegin von frontal 21 gesehen habe die
hat auf an der intensivstation gedreht
und wir journalisten sehen ja dann die
bilder unverpixelt und wir sehen auch
wie viel jüngere dort liegen mitten im
dreh geht auf einmal der alarm los und
es ist klar diese frau könnte jetzt
gerade sterben es ist lebensbedrohlich
und dann als all das vorbei ist er sagt
krankenschwester ich verstehe einfach
nicht warum sie nicht geimpft ist sie
versteht es nicht und die politik
versteht es natürlich auch nicht und die
politik scheint im moment nicht fähig es
zu ändern außer mit einer impfpflicht
das ist sozusagen ultima ratio das
letzte mittel am ende sind aber auch
viele der menschen die sich jetzt nicht
impfen lassen möchten oder können
ängstliche und diese ängste muss man
natürlich irgendwie auffangen oder ihnen
entgegenkommen ist die impfpflicht
wirklich das richtige mittel
[Musik]
eigentlich sollte ich jetzt ja schon
fast klar sein dass die impfpflicht
kommen muss um solche zustände zu
verhindern aber für die parteien ist es
nicht gleich gerade die fdp das ist ja
die liberale partei die für freiheit ist
und die soll für eine impfpflicht
stimmen wir sind eine liberale partei
für uns steht die selbstbestimmung ganz
vorne und das bezieht natürlich den
eigenen körper mit ein also lassen sie
sich impfen aber seien sie sicher mit
der fdp wird es keine impfpflicht geben
aber es gibt eine verpflichtung dass
sich jeder mit der frage der impfung
beschäftigt wenn jemand sich die
argumente vorlegt und prüft und abwägt
und ganzen ergebnis kommt nein ich lasse
mich nicht oder jetzt noch nicht impfen
dann habe ich davor respekt vor drei
wochen war der parteitag der ging es
eigentlich um den koalitionsvertrag aber
natürlich ging es am rande um die
impfpflicht denn die partei es
regelrecht zerrissen dadurch mehr als 20
abgeordnete unter anderem herr kubicki
haben sich ja schon dagegen
ausgesprochen es gab auch kürzlich einen
hintergrund mit christian lindner
hintergrund das ist ja so eine art
journalisten kreis wo er dann ohne
kameras noch mal darüber berichtet wie
bestimmte entscheidungen jetzt
vorangetrieben werden aus solchen
hintergründen darf man ja nicht
berichten und deshalb kann ich jetzt
auch nicht sagen was er auf meine frage
gesagt hat ob die partei jetzt bei
diesem thema impfpflicht einknickt in
anführungszeichen ich sage nichts ich
sage nur
schwierig
[Musik]
darf die politik nichts mehr versprechen
glaubwürdigkeit ist so ein hohes gut in
der politik war das ein fehler es
verhindert hatte ein fehler ganz zu
beginn der pandemie als man noch gar
nicht wusste wie sie sich entwickeln
würde eine impfpflicht auszuschließen
und dann bleibt nur noch das mittel den
druck zu erhöhen moralischen druck
finanziellen druck ausschließung aus
bestimmten gesellschaftlichen
aktivitäten und das vertieft natürlich
die spaltung die kommunikation war doch
im grunde völlig vermurkst stattdessen
hätte man einfach kommunizieren müssen
wir können jetzt nicht sagen wir können
nichts absehen wir müssen sehen was
passiert einen klaren umgang mit dem
thema zeigte im sommer annalena baerbock
von den grünen auf die frage ob sie eine
impfpflicht anstreben würde sagte sie
stand heute so macht man das als
politikerin nichts ausschließen aber
auch eine klare aussage treffen nur
leider ist das ja für uns journalisten
eigentlich das tägliche brot so ist das
eigentlich fast immer da kommt keine
klare kante sondern vielleicht
möglicherweise bleibt abzuwarten müssen
wir sehen das ist eigentlich wie
normalerweise kommuniziert wird das ist
eigentlich was wir auch gar nicht mögen
nur ausgerechnet in der pandemie da war
das plötzlich anders da sagten alle
impfpflicht nein wahrscheinlich haben
die meisten sich gedacht die kann ja
ähnlich kommen und das lag daran dass
fast alle verfassungsrechtler auch
gesagt haben eine impfpflicht ist in
deutschland nicht umsetzbar aber jetzt
ist es eben anders vielleicht haben ein
paar politiker sich auch gedacht wenn
wir jetzt handeln dann haben wir eine
sehr viel schwierigere situation eine
klare mehrheit der bevölkerung davon zu
überzeugen wir müssen noch zu warten bis
die situation so kritisch ist dass wir
dieses wendemanöver durchführen können
es geht um viel es geht um menschenleben
es geht um viele volle intensivstationen
die wahrheit ist ja würden sich mehr
impfen lassen dann hätten wir diese
diskussion gar nicht aber was bedeutet
das für das vertrauen in die politik was
wir gelernt haben sollten nach fast zwei
jahren pandemie ist dass eine solche
situation ganz viele unabsehbare
entwicklung mit sich bringt mutation und
ähnliches und dass man mit
ausschließeritis und endgültigen
festschreibe sehr sehr vorsichtig sein
sollte es wäre aber deutlich schlimmer
aus prinzipienreiterei bei seinem einmal
gegebenen wort zu bleiben auch wenn die
sachlage ein anderes handeln erfordert
und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir
jetzt ernsthaft über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht diskutieren wo noch viele
fragen zu klären sind das ist keine
leichtfertige sache aber eben auch sich
dabei zu entschuldigen und zu sagen das
hätte uns nicht passieren dürfen dass
wir das so rundheraus ausgeschlossen
haben das hat vertrauen gekostet und das
sollte kein zweites mal passieren nur
was können wir noch glauben können wir
überhaupt noch vertrauen ist es
vielleicht gerade gut wenn die politik
ihre einstellung verändert weil die
umstände dies erfordern sollte das
vielleicht für uns zu mehr vertrauen in
die politik führen oder ist genau das
gegenteil der fall ist das vertrauen für
immer verspielt was denkt ihr schreibt
es in die kommentare
vertrauen oder nicht vertrauen und jetzt
zum abschied noch ein kleines abschied
schminke für euch herr kubicki wurde von
mir gefragt warum er sich überhaupt
impfen um boostern lässt wenn er doch
eigentlich gegen eine impfpflicht ist
ich sage doch einmal ich habe mich
impfen und buchstaben das ändern wir das
auch mal weitermachen nicht weil ich die
gesellschaft schützen will sondern weil
ich mir selbst schützen will weil ich
dann keine angst vor unglück mehr haben
muss denn ich weiß mit dieser impfung
bin nicht so geschützt dass ich keine
schwere verläufe haben werde und
wahrscheinlich da gar nicht sterben
würden tja jeder hat so seine gründe
bitte bleibt und abonniert den kanal und
bis zum nächsten mal inside politics